hey guys what's up it's date fails It's
Me Kate we're back at all things comedy
I'm so happy to be in the studio people
always complain when I don't put up a
video I never do video when I'm not here
people just want to see that pretty face
they do I've never had someone no one
has ever been like hey we haven't seen a
video for in a while I get sad when you
don't post videos for a while and you're
well this is the first time here me too
yeah everybody feel about I think they
just want to see how sad I look every
week no no no new laws say they need
suffer this bang bang you just can't be
dudes yeah creepy dudes up on the date
fields podcast I'm sure that some of
that cave I don't think anyone is
jerking off to the gray background and I
don't think you know what color the
background is by the way I'm so sprung
on taupe like it's just my thing is this
taupe I don't know what do you mean
you're sprung on taupe taupe is the name
of your album gonna do spoken word yes
very folksy don't you think this hole
would make a great focusing or like she
has that vibe that look you do you
definitely should play one in a movie
okay pretty much Korean I should play ah
they said I have to play a like a crazy
doctor lady like your range is unlimited
crazy medical profession and then like
dirty hippie it's the same woman people
I agree I think how they blow out my
hair and if they brush it or not
actually both of them that's all your
acting is just wigs
[Laughter]
you're so right I'm a character actor
I'm like no you were [ __ ] way you
have yeah you have weird kooky glasses
without lenses in there yeah do your
glasses have lenses are real definitely
how well can you see without those fine
okay but not at night at night it's
really hard it's really bad how long
have you had glasses since I
man at high school I always wanted him
yes I think that I did not want because
my brother got teased he he had them
since he was a kid and he got teased
kids are so cute though with glasses
I agree how I can't I couldn't agree
more what's-his-face from Jerry friends
with him do you know him now no I don't
know I only see them on Instagram he's
my Stretch Armstrong he's a good guy
never even thought of it he's cute he's
hot he does jujitsu he's really really
sweet ooh this is a good move I love
that one of the things the pitch points
for you setting me up with him was not
that he was a child actor not that he's
funny cool but he's into the martial
arts yeah he's a fighter he's a fighter
and a lot of trained you know fighter
could run you through a workout I think
oh we see we see his account like six
months later and I'm like he looks like
[ __ ] stops doing jujitsu if you turn him
into a vegan I would kill you yeah can
we talk about how I try I've recently
been dating a guy who decided to turn
into a vegan and you know I dated a porn
actor with little hesitation but then
this guy I'm dating turned vegan and
he's an otherwise pretty good guy and
I'm like I cannot [ __ ] a vegan like I
literally I'm about to end it over this
vegan thing really I can't
every time we eat out now we have to eat
at a vegan well that's I understand that
yeah I don't I don't understand that I
you can't date someone if you don't have
similar taste in music you cannot date
someone if you do not have similar taste
in food and you cannot date someone if
you do not have similar taste in movies
and or jiu-jitsu I cut you off you were
gonna say that you were gonna say that
is if you're nothing to say belt level
you sure with a purple belt and he's
like red and
come on my best friend who you know Seth
Shapiro he not the real estate guy if
you try to follow him on Twitter and now
Jewish banker says Shapiro he could well
there's got to be one exactly ten at the
Wells Fargo branch everywhere in LA
every branch how many they have a minion
of Shapiro's but the thing is his wife
is vegan and as long as I've as long as
he's known her she's been vegan she was
vegetarian before and now she's vegan
and so and he doesn't he is what the not
vegan he's all the meat and you can't
work at Cheesecake Factory and be so
there was a girl who was a when I first
when I was there like ends ago so and
they may not have this policy anywhere
this woman was a or is a vegetarian
whatever and they go if she goes well
I'm not gonna able to eat this so you
know because they have a policy like hey
how is this thing and you know it's
amazing you're gonna love it
and she goes one vegetarian so I'll
never be able to eat this but you can't
tell your tables that yeah they had to
be like he had to be it's great well
here's the thing one if you're a vegan I
can date a vegan if that vegan doesn't
mind eating at real restaurants that
don't only serve vegan cuisine like oh
oh for sure yeah she's like she li did
all the restaurants yeah now we only
would go to vegan spots because he's a
new vegan yeah it's he doesn't have his
rhythm yet cuz like it was like Ian
Edwards
vegan rhythm the vegan rhythm it's it's
so real because Ian now I even prefers
obviously to go to vegan restaurants
yeah but like anytime I hang out with
him I'll be like hey can we go here and
he's like yeah I can find something
there you know it's just a matter of
like you just trusting that they're
right that their kitchen is just not
made of bone I think the vegan
restaurant should have kind of an option
like you know how they say like the ROS
lady at a lot of restaurants if you wink
at her she sells cocaine out of the back
alley I do a character about a guy who's
on a date like the to be learning date
and they character is his I just called
him a rose I supported a lady and and so
like the like I was trying to write this
sketch for it we're like the guy and
then it just me coming up as like sort
of like a gypsy woman I guess and being
a groceries for today and they're like
no no and they're trying to break up
and then so he just keeps offering
different things that might help in the
break-up and then he has a bag and you
don't realize it and it's like kind of
off-camera and he just keeps pulling
different things out a gun well they say
that the Rose ladies sell cocaine they
say if you give them the right weight
well the kids over at Fairfax High there
should be someone in vegan restaurants
who comes by and if you give them the
right like hand signal they like sneak
you some chicken they add some meat to
your dish guys in the comment section
let's figure this out I feel like
there's probably a reddit thread for
this for sure you know I I know this
musician named Moby who is a Moby I wish
you I wish you had given a last name so
we might have thought it was somebody
else I know musician Moby Carlsen is the
only one that they know in that category
there's him and then there's Fat Boy
slim and he's a distant second
I feel like Fat Boy slim is probably
mobis alter-ego it's still Moby his last
name is Fat Boy slim that sound like mew
mew does prada but it's two different
lines well be Fat Boy slim yeah so look
Moby has a vegan restaurant supposed to
be very good yeah I heard there I hear
their croissants on the weekend they
have for the brunch are phenomenal but
I'm a croissant girl I'll go I'll go the
distance
okay so vegan croissants but here's what
I'm saying so mo be told me that when he
opened you guys write a first name only
basis yeah Karlsson slash Fat Boy slim
causes middle name for those no no I'm
I'm very close with
Oh mommy told me that when he opened his
restaurant he hired only chefs who eat
meat because he wanted the food to taste
good so I'm like so wait so you're a
vegan but you're admitting that food
with meat tastes better first of all let
me just say one thing I know the singer
Madonna not the virgin wait like like a
virgin similar to but not
I know Michael Jordan Horowitz who also
works with the 10th St Rose it's always
bulls themed I don't know why all right
but this so there there's a restaurant
my favorite restaurant in the world is
called next and it's in Chicago and it's
um this chef named Greta Grant Achatz
did this thing where he changes the menu
four times a year or three times a year
and so he'll do a menu and they'll pick
something like the Baku store which is
the competition in France and then they
will do all of the dishes so be like 20
courses or they'll like pick a specific
the best like they'll do like um Japan
Kyoto they have a chi sexy style banquet
which is like a traditional way to eat
in Kyoto so they redid that and that was
the menu right so they did a vegan menu
once I think once I've only had it there
well it was it was the most unhealthy
they say and they didn't do they only
did one round where something was a meat
flavored thing everything else was just
trying to find its way around and they
said it was the by far the most
unhealthy meal they have that healthy
yeah I'm being a ton of nuts so you're
getting a lot of fat well a lot of the
food to make it taste better they add
extra fat extra salt sugar my brother
works at a vegan bakery you know so much
it was just like like um you know when
they make like gingerbread houses or
something like it like if it's not candy
literally it's just like sugar in the
shape of something that was like
everything of the bakery yeah it's crazy
people think it's being healthy they're
like well it's healthy animals not that
you can not that you can't be a vegan
because you can do it and do it
healthily if you know how but you can't
just it's like when people to say I'm
gonna go gluten-free and they just think
that's healthy well it's also that
everybody
an expert yes that's the big I think
that's the big like how I turn this into
like a vendetta against Vienna
no no just because I'm mad at the guy
just know that your dates are failing if
you're a vegan or your glutes bring it
back to the name yeah speaking of date
fails let's go into this enough about
this vegan [ __ ] first of all I do have
to say one thing before we move on that
I'm a [ __ ] and I reckon I didn't even
need to I know people know this but I
know knows it Roby Carlton Fatboy Slim
if you're just joining us it's a moment
Carlton that was all I read last week
forecast for mattresses and they were
they were upset because I left out an
important detail that I need to put in
to this podcast today which is if you
would like a Casper mattress yeah it's a
go to Casper dot-com backslash date
fails and use my discount code date
fails wait will Casper just give me a
mattress and some a guest on the it's
possible I could work out a deal for you
I hope I'm telling you I'm literally in
the market for a new mattress I swear to
you you should actually try this because
I'm not I'm not saying this because they
advertise on my show it's cool because
you order it online it comes to you for
free you can try it for I think it's a
hundred nights and then send it back for
free if you don't like it Wow
so it's basically like there's no risk
to it it's like an Airbnb that comes to
you it's like how is this like it's
Airbnb for cars you can rent a car now
yeah like Zipcar right it's like it no
it's so it's like it's just a normal
person doing it it's not a corporation
oh god I do that now if I want to hook
up with a guy and we can't afford a
hotel room I just get one of those
Airbnb cars and we do it in the car I
have a joke that I'm working on no no I
actually have a joke that I'm working
right now about how my apartment is
speaking of like Dave fails back to the
name of the podcast they um that that I
saying like it's so hard to park in my
neighborhood that I whenever I just want
to take a girl back to my place I'm like
let's just do it in your car then I'm
like I'm like my dating now is a
drive-by because like there's no there's
you have to have
it's now where I live and they keep
changing them so it's like if you're not
there by a certain time you're screwed I
remember one time when I was over at
your place there's like a you guys can't
get a permit for your place well we
can't I now have a to a spot in the back
yeah so it just shows how long you owe
the street please come over and I have
if I have anybody you recently please
was right right when Jeff was moving out
I thought you're gonna say right when
Obama started his new stream but I mean
I think I have to admit I hate having
sex in my apartment because I don't like
my apartment so anytime I start acting
makes my [ __ ] drier up and a dry up
faster that a bad apartment I don't want
to have sex in my apartment I don't the
bed moves a lot and the place is hot and
I just I just like guys know Kate sport
Fox I do I just like the bed moves a lot
of room okay I sweat a lot I treat it
like a workout
like you know they usually hold you
you're holding ham and she just [ __ ]
she's on a Stairmaster don't get to ten
thousand calories burned I keep [ __ ]
I didn't you [ __ ] got a bone under
both legs you're one of the exercises
you're wrapped in trash bags like Martin
Lawrence what he passed that on sighs I
don't think so and then the guy tries to
push my legs over my head I'm I don't do
that let me do it myself
I was the extra burn I need I need to
push no but like so when I go out with a
guy now I either have to get to his
place first to make sure it's an okay
place to hook up in or I make them get
hotel rooms every time every time that's
my new thing like I can't get it I can't
get a guy to take me to dinner and
you're like I'm gonna need you to get a
hotel room no but if the guy if I know
the guy has money I wouldn't do this to
like I wouldn't just [ __ ] I know I would
thought the poor guy in his in his house
there's a party your bed
statements before I asked this hotel
room so I can see what star we get
reception is your bank statement no my
favorite contraceptive is my apartment
you know that I [ __ ] poor guys we all
know that I [ __ ] poor guys that should
be the day with this podcast I [ __ ]
poor guy it should be we [ __ ] four
guys and I'm always on it even though
you're the we all have [ __ ] poor guys
here God knows but like not me yeah I
was there I've been I've been that half
of the equation I'm just saying I'd
rather [ __ ] a poor guy in his apartment
then [ __ ] a rich guy in my apartment I
would rather [ __ ] a poor guy oh that is
some math it's true but like having a
porking a poor guy at your apartment is
great because he thinks you're a goddamn
[ __ ] sugar mama Queen uh I guess I
just need to get a new bed maybe Casper
could send me a new bed to go with my
mattress that's what this is about
my god let me just say the part of that
is bangs on the wall it's so loud yeah
you you need a new friends yeah or a new
technique no lateral back and forth or
or get like um get like a bench press
bar like or a pad where you can lay back
and do this well for a while I had a
pool noodle because my bed is like iron
so I have one of those like in the
throne yeah where is this room was like
antique-looking like it's like it looks
like a 12 year old girls bad like it's
like white baby that's what it is
breaker of chains yeah 12 year-old girls
beds are not meant to be [ __ ] done
you're like I got this from from Dubai
though well it's the Brandis child's
bride this is crazy why do you get that
Ben I put full noodles behind it you
have bumpers what is that she go see you
always get a strike in the [ __ ] all
right why would we start with the
dialogue there
well alright I want to talk about what's
going on your guys my love life for my
listeners last week I said I ended it
with this guy that I've been seeing
which I really pretty much did for the
most part although you know he was
talking to me about it she's like I feel
like I might have [ __ ] it up I was
like no you didn't I thought [ __ ] up
no you didn't I'm never working let me
tell him cuz he's an ass it was never
well I [ __ ] it up a little you don't
think okay no Kate you just [ __ ]
threw gasoline on the fire that was
already burning and was gonna burn out
you're probably right and you just
accelerated the inevitable the guy I've
been seeing
we aren't exclusive okay but have you
ever been dating someone where it's not
exclusive but it's almost like you're in
a relationship because haha % know
you're like good night every night it's
like texting every day you're seeing
each other a couple times a few times a
week whatever so before you know it it's
like yeah there's no label but there's
some level of like you know of
interesting yeah so then this guy he's
an actor and he booked a movie and he
was only shooting a movie for like I
don't know six days or something not
that long but basically I hear from this
guy every day every night every day
every night then he gets this movie and
he kind of goes like am i a right and
then when I asked him about it he was
like well this is how I am when I'm
working when I'm like in it I just I'm
in this zone I don't like to have a lot
of outside conversation which I get when
you're like on set when you're shooting
that's what I said I go if this was
Daniel day-lewis I would understand
actually as a method actor it's like a
hallmark movie about the day the bear
saves Christmas you know to be fair to
him it's like it was like here's the
half owns know to be fair to him it's a
big movie it's a big opportunity for him
and so like I understand but my thing is
I'm like no matter what I'm doing no
matter how in the zone I am on a gig at
the end of the night when I'm done or
I'm in my trailer I'm whatever I'm not
working working my brain isn't like I
can't think of anyone or anything sure
this so I kind of called him out on it
this is why he's a movie star okay no
you called him out on it what happened I
called him out on it and basically uh he
was pissed that I called him out on it
cuz he was like you should be nothing
but supportive right now this is like
one week we're talking about like even
if you don't hear from me who gives a
[ __ ] and I was like okay but I'm still a
girl and at the end of the day you went
from everyday attention to suddenly
nothing yeah that's that part for me is
I think it's just annoying to me it's
like don't don't have nothing going on
and I'm your main focus a yeah all of a
sudden you have something you're saying
even shoot off a [ __ ] text that's how
it made me feel I'm sorry everybody
takes a [ __ ] with their phone totally
shoot off a [ __ ] [ __ ] text that's how
it made me feel like oh now you suddenly
got this movie so like I'm I'm not that
important or even worse that in your
head you're like oh I got this [ __ ] now
[ __ ] her like that's kind of 2017 and so
the thing is when somebody doesn't
respond to a text or whatever there's no
excuse like there was a thing that
happened to me where I was trying to
work with this guy and then he wouldn't
respond and I was just like all you had
to do is be like can't or whatever you
can little one word right but it doesn't
make sense like nobody's doing unless
you're in the army and I mean like
everybody has their phone with them all
the time and it's not like he left it at
home and then went like on location for
six days he said there's no reception on
set we're not allowed to bring phones on
set but I'm still like okay but there's
some reception at some point when you're
replying back being like [ __ ] off I'm in
the middle of a movie so like you're
shooting Walking Dead you have to go off
the [ __ ] great yeah yeah like you're
shooting a movie right you go home at
the end of the night you're not in the
middle of [ __ ] no
so this all happened but the reason I
said it was a little bit my fault is
because in hindsight I'm like it was six
days could I have waited and chilled and
kind of had this conversation when it
was over versus like getting upset and
giving him [ __ ] while he's trying to
shoot this movie because that's what
ended up happening is we end up kind of
like arguing about it while he's making
the movie which just made it worse and
then when I got back he suddenly is like
look I mean you thought this was way
more than a
is I thought it was like super casual
and I'm like to be fair you're texting
me every [ __ ] night good night
telling me what you're doing guys don't
tell girls what they're doing no it's
super when it's super casual they're not
like hey I'm doing this tonight I'm
doing this like so anyway we got into it
but what I think is funny and where the
date fail comes in is I am such a crazy
[ __ ] psycho because over the course
of 12 hours like we decided it was done
and then I said okay and then he kept
texting me and then I was like well
maybe we can just keep [ __ ] and then
I was like maybe we should just be
friends no lose my number I mean I
changed my whole mind like 17 times in
the course of like 12 hours and I'm like
is that a ring on your finger this is
just a ring oh I thought it was his I'm
like and now we're engaged my tribal
bride I'm a psycho is what I'm saying I
can't that's made him his bow but that's
this is the problem though she says this
day crap director biggert I don't want
to give up the sex but I can't just keep
[ __ ] him or it'll never eat what do
you mean you don't want to give up the
sex like there's other sex out there I
know but you know when you have that
really hot dirty like like it's hard to
find like really hot dirty sex with
someone you have a great chemistry with
yeah how often do you find that it's
literally ever found it never had hot
dirty sex yeah and then it ends and then
that's it it's over I'm not like I'm not
like trying to have a relationship with
the dude you're only trying to have a
relationship you're trying to make a ho
a housewife I was gonna you know you're
trying to do is you're trying to like
have the porn happen and then see what
crazy adventures you go on at Home Depot
like this is the thing this guy we hung
out for like three months before we had
sex so it wasn't like my usual period
for three months
because I I was really fighting hooking
up with him I told you about this
because he's in the industry and I'm
really trying to avoid dating guys in
this business so when we met I was kind
of into him but I was like I'm not gonna
[ __ ] this guy we're gonna be friends and
we really started to it back to me what
no I'm thinking about all of our
conversations right now yes now you know
so like so
him I was like we both had this thing
where it was like we shouldn't do it but
we like each other so let's kick it and
then we were both kind of we went back
and forth like there would be nights I'd
be like let's just [ __ ] who cares and
he'd be like no I don't think we should
then there be nights he would want to
and I'd be like it's a bad idea so we
put it off for three months which we
actually started to like each other so
now it's more complicated than just
someone you're [ __ ] do you think you
could hang out with him without [ __ ]
him nope Wow I am a sex addict that yeah
still you're focusing for that guy
taking the time can you just go from
let's say it was you yes let's say this
is about you okay what if it was how
weird would that be crazy about you look
over at me and I'm just like AHA so you
can't hang out with this person without
[ __ ] take your dick out right now
what if we what if it was me and you
yeah okay are you a naughty girl and
then you know you like her a lot but
yeah she's gonna be a little more work
than you want cuz you are focused on
your career huh then could you just keep
kicking it with her or not [ __ ] if you
guys have like amazing sex in chemistry
I think that would be on my mind I think
that would be a real hard it'd be really
hard it would be I think it would be
yeah it's harder I know we're all Philip
Seymour Hoffman from happiness you beat
you have everything around you and you
reach for a wall
I know he pig as common as Hannah go
yeah good movie so never never new come
could be spackle but there you have it
so wait a minute you're telling me
Nicole that you could be having
amazingly hot sex with a guy but then
you know you realize there's no future
for it just stop yep done
I know I can do it for a little bit
longer but now I would I would never
even be having a conversation about it
because I was having good sex with a guy
for like a year and a half and I
realized there was nothing nothing there
at all so I would just after we'd have
sex sometimes I would just be on my
phone I'm like tindering or bumbling or
whatever and one time he caught me and
he's like what are you doing that with
me right in the bed and I was like yeah
yeah is this going somewhere and he's
like well I don't know he's like I'm
like I didn't think this was going
anywhere he's like why would you think
that I'm like okay well then tell me
otherwise is this going somewhere and he
was like yeah yeah and I'm like exactly
let's just keep this [ __ ] casual then
like let's just call this what it is and
once I accepted that reality he had a
hard time with it that's exactly what
happened that's exactly what happened
yesterday because I told this guy I
finally after our time you were calling
his bluff you were trying to manipulate
him with sex no no no no no before this
before that I didn't talk about that yet
but what happened yesterday is so we met
up we had a long talk he basically said
I think you want more than me we got to
quit I feel like we're doing a talkback
show by the way for your sex life like
so they you don't I mean like how they
do like like the walking dead and the
talking dead and you just jumped ahead
to another episode of exploit alert I
just we had this coffee and he told me
it's done you know he said I think we
should stop right and I actually he was
annoying me so bad yesterday he was
being so just like douchey and cold
about it and so like whatever I was like
cool okay no problem yeah so we got up
and I kind of give Mike a half-ass hug
and then I walked away and I knew I
looked really cute because I came from a
meeting so I had on like a backless
dress with like a short skirt right now
meetings backless dress in short skirt
it was a meeting it was a call it was a
second it was a second interview for a
for a busser position at TGI Fridays for
a hot girl job it was for like a hot
girl hosting gig so I hope that's why
I've never had one of those okay me
either
I know I only I was a veil for the
ailment for oh my ass lips for True
Blood I was the the standby for the lips
like is what this is about in the ass
lips yeah that was my impression of my
ass I think I have roid flap just guys
welcome back to date fails we're talking
about [ __ ] and have an anal fissure
no that's our other sponsor I walked
away and then as soon as I started
walking away he was like wait this is a
weird way to end it and I was like it's
always a weird way to end it right and
then I think it's always weird but then
he ended up texting me like kind of the
rest of the day like kind of
backpedaling you know it's like I'm not
on set right now we've got so much time
I didn't book anything but then I did
something really kind of great but
stupid but I told Nicole about this
which is like so we're arguing and work
texting back and forth and we're still
going through it and then finally I said
I have an idea
terrible idea can we just put this talk
on hold just pause and I just come over
and we [ __ ] you know I thought you were
gonna say can we just put this talk on
hold for six days fixing this bed
noodles not the sponsor for this oh my
god works really what if you need to
bumper your bed but a life hack it just
it's as utility of you [ __ ] but like
you can't tell and it just cuts to the
core do you have a really loud annoying
bed guys
don't get a new bed get home get a foam
dick
I buy over the 99-cent store you can get
like five years
okay maybe you should quickly cake
Quigley's
foam dicks oh [ __ ] Kate that's your new
merch actually wanted to do a YouTube
show about turning 99-cent store items
into sex toy I'd watch that
trademark trademark trademark so the
point is the point is what do you think
I think this is a great tactic that you
could use but I'm such a sex addict like
when I get here's a problem when I get
angry at someone it makes me want to
[ __ ] them more because I love angry I
hate sex I love hate so the more I get
mad at you or upset about the situation
the more I just want to [ __ ] you so what
happens is in the middle of the five
guys are just gonna try pissing you off
all the time now I know the fight I just
said can we pause this conversation and
have sex and then pick it back up
tomorrow we're you guys fighting over
text or the phone tags this guy won't
talk on the phone what did ya what does
he have a sidekick yeah no he has a
thing about talking on the phone he
won't he'll only talk that's the other
thing he'll only talk in person
that's what I told him the first day we
had this argument on what is he what is
he the guy from the from Goodfellas I
know all he didn't like anyone hearing
when he canvassed agent so we had a guy
deliver all of his meds like what he'll
send me voice notes and videos but he
won't talk on the phone so the first day
we're having this whole like argument
thing when he's on his movie I said to
him
call me for five minutes so we can talk
about this and if you really need me to
leave you alone for a few days I will
but like just call me and he won't talk
on the phone that's insane
he doesn't do phone calls he's like I
don't even call my mom I'm like so
you're telling me your [ __ ] phone calls
or his bracket thank you yeah a hundred
percent yeah this guy's 47 okay his deck
works I know it's weird he has a good
deck there was a lot of yeah there's a
lot of pause there you're a forty seven
you're like
you're like yeah I know well she said
she was like I was so surprised as dick
works and he can [ __ ] for a while yeah
he's on pills no no I'm telling you she
knows pills dick
I know pill dick that's ain't it let's
talk about your love lives enough about
mine what's going on with you two I mean
last time to close on the show she
hadn't had sex for a year well I'm
almost there I have I've had sex twice
in two years because I went from having
rampant sex to having like no sex why
because it's like oh you know I kind of
have a joke about it in my stand-up but
it's just like sex is very costly dude
you don't tell it here come see her at
the improv tonight comedy living room in
the lab tonight are you this airs
tomorrow by the way I'm gonna say that
I'm gonna say this on there we did a
show last week together yeah I'm telling
you those jokes you're crushed so funny
okay where was the show at The Improv
and in the lab yeah the impro lab and
that audience was like that audience and
then and then I was hosting the show and
then Jonathan went up after me and did a
bunch of impressions and his impressions
are amazing thank you for the listeners
who don't know Jonathan just look up his
impression I mean look up everything he
does he's hilarious but like his
impressions are some of the best I have
ever seen ever in this business and we
live in a town where there's a lot of
[ __ ] talented people but he got off
stage and I just felt like the crowd was
like applauding and they were happy but
I don't think they realized like what
they had just witnessed like like you're
clean understand like it's just it was
so infuriating to me that crap but that
was such a funny to the lineup was so
strong so like one of the strongest
lineups I've ever been because I've been
on awesome lineups in that little improv
lab room and if it's not completely full
it's almost like the crowd sometimes is
like they feel like they're watching in
a library if you like a beat poetry like
a coffee shop when it's not full for
people who don't live in I should've
done my sprung on top work
for the people who don't live in LA the
Improv lab room is basically kind of
like the belly room at the Comedy Store
which is like a small it seats like
maybe 56 I love I love the belly my arms
one my favorite rooms in comedy I
actually like the impro because I'll
tell you that stuff that when we were
doing the lab when I did a lab maybe
like six months ago or not that was the
way to long ago like a month ago maybe I
was working on some of those impressions
and the good thing about that is like
there was a decent sized crowd but like
I remember doing and I have it now but I
didn't have it then I was doing a louis
c.k like telling a bedtime story to his
kid and like it bombed so hard but like
i didn't feel bad about it like when i
with that impression like I didn't it
was like just enough so like in that
room not that I tried a bomb by the way
if you're listening and you own the
improv but it's like it was like I felt
comfortable to like try out stuff there
and it was awesome like the other stuff
worked great there's a couple
impressions that didn't I was sort of
going back and forth but like when that
set that I and I appreciate that but I
think that the set that I did on last
week was like top to bottom like the
whole way through it was amazing and
people appreciate it I just don't think
they appreciated it enough it was like
one of those crowds or it's like not
badly no it was weird because like you
went and then Laura Kiely her and it was
and then me and then and then who was
after Brendon Walsh was on the show
right it was like so many good people
and they were just like golf clapping it
was I'm telling you when it's not full
like I did a show recently there with
Sam Tripoli jim Florentine
Eleanor Kerrigan like an awesome line
and it was very similar like and Sam Sam
Tripoli is so [ __ ] yeah he's I can't
watch him without laughing and I mean
even him they were laughing but they
were just kind of like holding back yeah
tell it it was a lot of it was a lot of
people like covering their mouths when
they laugh I call it the Asian lap
before they just like cover their mouth
it's very polite and I was like just
[ __ ] for our Asian listeners this is
how we your version was he were like you
were not you were that's unlike an Asian
woman with a man and yours was like an
old kung-fu master
what I was gonna say so that really fits
so by the way China Lipnicki if you're
listening Johnny's gonna I'm gonna hook
that [ __ ] oh wait so you said you hadn't
had sex yeah why are you so you had a
joke about it I rudely interrupted you
well it's like I don't know it's it's
like unless I really like you at this
point like I don't wanna I just don't
even want to waste the amount like once
you start having sex as a woman you have
to go to the gynecologist regularly you
like that you're I don't I don't know
what your Planned Parenthood called me
last week and we're like where have you
been they send out cards I swear to God
I was like when did you start
telemarketing they were like we see you
haven't been here in two years and I was
like they send you a follow-up card like
the way the dentist does yeah that's
great okay so so you're saying you don't
[ __ ] because you don't want to have to
go through the medical expenses it's
just so annoying and it's like getting a
bikini wax or shave these are feeling I
don't have the money to a cheaper
no it's I'm gonna set you up with my
laser girl 50% off of a thousand dollars
it's not a lot of [ __ ] money it's not
it's $1.99 for six treatments you okay I
don't I literally don't have that money
if there is a guy out there who wants to
pay guys [ __ ] donate all right don't
donate we start a Kickstarter for
nakaya's yeah I will if there's a guy
there's got to be one guy who listens to
Kate who's got some spare change he can
throw my way if you pay for me to get
lasered I will send you or you've got
eight shots of my legs shut up I will
send you pictures of me getting laser
you can't do that I don't give a [ __ ] Oh
still online your kid who keeps your
[ __ ] on the internet I mean it's
probably somewhere out there good point
my jennifer lawrence's is you think
you're better than Jennifer Lawrence
guys Nicole would like her vagina laser
blasted you should come with me I always
periscope it when I do can they just do
our vaginas like yours each look like
half a heart so when you put your
[ __ ] together it's true love so
you've only had sex twice in two years
when was the last time
so you're definitely not like I mean I
get great if I don't have sex for a week
I start to go into eventually I if you
get past the point I'm like I mean I do
care I do want to have sex but it's like
I don't know it's just like I fine I
also have this problem with I really
really like a guy I'm scared to have sex
with him cuz if it's bad I'm gonna stop
liking that's what I thought too but you
know this last dude the first time
actually this is hilarious the first
time we had sex it was just okay and I
left and I was like this is good because
it was good but it wasn't great
so I'm not gonna get hung up on this guy
cuz the sex is just okay and then every
time we had sex it's like he was he got
better like it was almost like he was
reading or she was like no it was just
going to say he was adapting he evolving
yeah oh and now it's subtle because now
he's figured out like everything that I
like and so now we're talking about him
like he's uh like he's a terminator he's
learning my [ __ ] no no he's artificial
intelligence it's it's just him it's
like the fifth element when Lilu is just
like like reading everything your [ __ ]
and Lila was the name of a vibrator but
see is that true I don't and by the way
is that the greatest hungry eyes ever
she goes hungry thighs you're an actor
though see I feel like actor sex is the
best sex because they start using an
accent what would it sound like if Vince
Vaughn was [ __ ] me what's your
subtext what do you want no no what is
it what are you asking
no because whatever like the girl is
into you can kind of like take on that
you know if the girls into like you know
you like breaking into her house and
[ __ ] or like then scenario that's
running through your mind where you're
like you know what I'm having a
hankering for that you've been a
burglary
you know I can't find on this show is
someone who pretend to break in will
force his way into me
you guys I live right down the street
from Kate so if you want to forcibly
break and enter into her apartment
just give me a buzz and I will be there
for the rest of a great scenario stop by
with the donation money have the money
available for my lasering we can just do
it right there at her apartment and I'll
provide the ski mask yes perfect I've
never been asked that I mean but like I
watched that porn like in two wait horn
waits intruder porn is very much a real
thing but what are some of the weirdest
[ __ ] you for that yeah what have you
been asked for I I know that I'm you
think I'm getting out of this one easy I
don't get asked to do that weird [ __ ]
girls don't ask you to do accent they'll
probably ask you to do impression do
girls everyone not referring to girls
ask you to [ __ ] them as as the guy that
you play girls no oh my god I would
totally be into the world it's never I
swear to God
especially though he has ice and listen
I swear to you it has never happened why
do you think that is I would they don't
realize it's me yes they do can I tell
you something there's so for the
audition for the audition for his part
for two burgers I've know Jonathan for a
really long time the best we've been
friends forever and forever so like way
before I ever did stand-up and I knew I
knew Jonathan was he working when he was
working in a restaurant and I would like
come over I was really good friends with
his roommate who was who's his cousin
yeah and I would come over and Jonathan
would just be locked in his room working
on impressions like all day long was
obsessed obsessed obsessed with getting
it right and and what was the point of
my story oh yeah so when I remember when
you were auditioning for two Broke Girls
yeah you told me about it he had gone in
they were only looking for a Russian
guys they were fifty year old guys what
he is portraying and he went in there
dressed as the part was wearing like a
wife beater put a mustard stain on his
shirt like went in there like full real
deal and went in there speaking in the
accent it's not like he went in there
right right right
hi I'm Jonathan like he went in there
like as that character I'd [ __ ]
crushed it it's amazing thank you yeah I
mean it was but it's one of those things
where I felt like it's such a weird
thing so now that I've shaved and I've
cut my hair it's like super short yeah
nobody nobody no I'll tell you what
happened the other day I was at the
Grove and these really sweet there are
these three
I don't know they'd probably like
between 10 and 15 and their mother and
they were visiting from Beirut and they
like I was like this and I was in a hat
like you could never have told it was me
and it from the back they were like hey
can we come up and get a picture with
you and I was like how the hell so I was
wearing a burka that said you broke
girls that's why that said me did they
think you were someone else
no they were like oh you're Oleg right
and I was like and I turned stunned and
I was like yeah are you trying to serve
me paper I was like how did I go yes I
went nyet and then we laughed and there
was they were so nice they were so nice
and I couldn't believe that they
recognized me because I think that I
don't get recognized yeah I went to the
improv last night and um one of the door
guys came up to me and like he kind of
not brushed past me but he was like oh
and then he turned he went oh my god he
goes I didn't recognize you yeah well
yeah you wouldn't I mean honestly like I
was even I was watching your show I
watched an episode of the show on my
flight recently and I was thinking that
it was like I would never what airline
was it was in virgin Delta Thank You
Delta thank you by the way thank you
Delta because some of the airlines carry
me when I watch you on that show and the
way you walk on that show like I just
know the way you walk so well like when
Kate said that you were coming to do the
podcast today I was like does he know
I'm gonna be on the show and she's like
no I'm like I know exactly how he's
gonna greet me like in my head so it's
like if I watch you on the show it's
like I see your physicality like even
though you are Oleg like I'm still like
oh that's yeah you know I have tried
I'll tell you because I'm doing the show
my stance was really exaggerated more
than how I move like then it wasn't
normally be and I have worked on my
posture so much since getting the show
because I had such a it was like a deep
Bend and like the small of my back I'd
have to stay like that for a long time
and so even though I was like sort of
comfortable that area before because I
could sort of move in and out of it in
life when you have to stand like that
for to set shots and stuff it started to
hurt my back and so now my posture I
think is so much better because of the
show you can imagine how
your back hurts like could you imagine
you're stand-in like dude's got
permanent scoliosis Yeah right
oh he's you know they just know they
know no we hired someone who right yeah
weird equal opportunist so wait so
what's up with you last time I saw you
you were super duper single you know we
are super do well in this we talked
about when I had lunch with the other
day I have been out of town for the past
two three months I feel like when you're
not working you're always traveling
you're never here that is a hundred
percent true I started going out on the
road a lot more number one because I got
offered a lot of rooms that I couldn't
turn down because I love them so much
stand-up you mean yeah yeah vacation no
no so then then I went to every year my
childhood best friend and I take a trip
together around fourth of July just cuz
he lives in a different city and like
we're still super close so we always
planned this to be like let's go
somewhere so we can still keep hanging
out because I don't the people in my
life are all the same people and like
the way I do that is by sort of you know
really taking the time to say hey let's
do this yeah and that's what this the
friendships are so strong so we went to
South America and so we went to Columbia
and we went to Peru just like you know
hiking backpack and stuff it was super
fun and then I went and did more
stand-up and I came back so I just
haven't been here the entire summer yeah
so I think it's weird for me now see
that is a guy who can't get back to you
know dad is a guy he's he's out of
[ __ ] town yeah we're out of the
country in another time yes in another
hemisphere so it's like for me though
and he's still wood that's the best part
like of ID I'm you on Instagram probably
within like a week I would hear back no
I would text you that day
see but you I text you the other day and
then you really do want to do this but
it's like here's what I would say in
terms of what's important at the end of
the day if some if he's and I don't know
what happened but if somebody text me
and said hey I don't know Tom Hanks is
interested in meeting you sorry I was
unset for six days could not happening
here right you like we we you prioritize
new to a hundred percent and so when I
was on the road I
called my parents my father had a cancer
scare when I was out of the country and
he's like totally good now he's 100%
clean and it's amazing but I made sure
no matter where I was I called him like
every other day and so but just because
you do do you know because that's what I
mean about priorities it wasn't to be
liked but that's like a huge priority we
didn't know what was going on so like
you call because you are able to because
it's not and I wasn't like in the Amazon
and even when we went to the jungles
which we did go to for a few days we
always made it back by the end of the
night you you like we just did oh yeah
and if we didn't we were taken by
banditos no totally I mean I did a
military tour overseas and we were at
times in places with no service
eventually you get back to Wi-Fi or
something and you well that's the thing
there are very few places that I can
tell you is somebody who and I there's a
I have it I've been to pretty remote
areas yeah you would be shocked how much
Wi-Fi there is right now
my ex went to Antarctica he went to
Antarctica and he texts me from like a
base that well it's also because of
satellites right there is so much of it
now and like I would say a few years ago
I went to Japan and the Wi-Fi or like
the service was crap world Canyon still
a [ __ ] dead zone America America
Japan I would have a easier time
understanding if he didn't get back to
if he was like you know what I'm
shooting in Laurel Canyon
I'd be like yep total dead zone yeah
you're right or if he said I have
Cricket Wireless yeah I get it
there's a guy that I was kicking it with
for a minute who was a football player
and your roster is amazing by the way I
love that I used roster terminologies by
the way your roster is like the next
season of Dancing with the Stars - the
dance floor no I but you know it's not
they're not all like that I'm just using
this guy's I mean yeah I know what you I
know the roster you've you've had I mean
it's amazing it's a celebrity charity
game we're saying as losers also have a
chance sorry you guys production needs a
set PA okay guys don't count yourself
out listen I got mad because red band
said oh you've turned into a star
[ __ ] and I was like I don't think that
about you at all because I'm a star
we've never had sex thank you thank you
well this is the thing it's not that I'm
trying to starve [ __ ] it's just that
it's it's like if I have these guys
asking if I'm a football player asking
me out and I have the guy that works at
my 7-eleven asking me out I'm not gonna
lie I'll probably go out with the
football player first just put any any
girl who says different is a [ __ ]
liar yeah yeah but it doesn't mean I
wouldn't give 7/11 if I - I have seven
Oleg I played college football yeah this
guy's Pro no child like flag football
like rec league yeah come on get over
yourself - don't [ __ ] NFL's
yeah but this NFL football player one
day he texts me during halftime
that's not even allowed I was like this
[ __ ] texted me during halftime
so like now on I was like any guy that
ever is like I'm doing my zone like [ __ ]
you this guy text me during halftime
hashtag touchdown you know I mean this
is why I only [ __ ] guys who have no jobs
because they have all that they have no
excuse all of my insecurities and they
will [ __ ] me like it's their job because
it is their only job they have em and by
the way I always think is people with
anything in life and I and I don't
[ __ ] yes but people getting back
people yes but it's time people I don't
have time people without jobs richandtim
all they got is like a trust fund in
time yeah yeah that is why I'm usually
with poor guys because I can manipulate
them and keep them for and I also like
guys who are who are newly sober so I
can be their new drug of choice hang
outside of like a a meetings and yeah I
come off I hate you outside of AAA
meetings and the unemployment when you
get laser by the way you should get
written over your [ __ ] black tar heroin
you and I should start going to like
addicts meetings just to pick up God
it's like can we go this is a great
that's from Fight Club remember that's
what Helena Bonham Carter does oh yeah
yeah yeah the daters keep going to
meetings and then she well I'm not the
club itself I didn't say anything
could've been a [ __ ] fight club sandwich
what if it's the sandwich that's on the
menu but they
or talk about can i order the fight club
sandwich would you that's an old
reference Jonathan guys you guys done
the movie big right anyway number three
how like 80s Tom Hanks just laughing at
his own movies you know big right Club
well well guys welcome to Fight Club
okay first rule is you do not talk about
Fight Club okay Tom Hanks Tom Hanks I'm
holding running out of breath I do he
was my idol really he's like four guys
growing up Michael Keaton Tom Hanks Jim
Carrey and John Lithgow oh I love Jim
Carrey I was I don't get starstruck very
often yes
I recently because they're inside me
she's like can I just say no or the
regular carpet is rolled out for you or
the record my number is still pretty
[ __ ] low it's still under 30 if you
round down no it's really still under 30
30 stars 30 people total 30 people who
were on IMDB his top 50 no no I am DB
rating I have only [ __ ] two actors
that are actually like successful three
okay what she's trying to say about is
if she's [ __ ] a lot of actors but
y'all weren't [ __ ] no what I'm saying is
there was like there have been a couple
other actors I [ __ ] that I didn't know
how successful they were and then I'd be
watching a show and be like hey that guy
like I didn't know but there's only two
that are like household name type the
actors I don't [ __ ] a lot okay what it
needs to be like the musician Mobe
exactly I don't think I want ya to list
their credits you would have to let
their occupation their name
um I would like to say that I think that
three of us should take a trip somewhere
a weekend getaway like how much fun will
we have all the fun I haven't taken a
trip for fun where do you want to go I
don't know I want to go to you know
where I want to go I want to go to Costa
Rica and like zipline and play with
monkey let's do it so I let me tell you
I went to Costa Rica for a bachelor
party yeah it was one of the most fun
times you know who was there
milliner was there hey Aaron whiner yeah
a buddy of ours oh really is that and we
actually became he's a comic any super
[ __ ] funny and this guy's one of his
best friends so Aaron and I became
incredibly close on this weekend I
remember it was so it was so fun so we
so they were so a buddy of ours Jake
White was like I'm getting married and
which we all knew and super happy for
him he's like we're gonna go to Costa
Rica so can you take a break so I
literally left set of two Broke Girls
and then I flew directly to Costa Rica
with this guy and it was so cool because
I had already been great friends with
Jake but Aaron and I became like
amazingly close on the trip and all we
did was like we went whitewater rafting
and Aaron the reason I bring him up was
we went on level four level five Rapids
and we were the we were the strongest
paddlers cuz I had done it a lot and so
would he and I actually flipped out of
the raft going this speed of the river
and I was under the water the under the
raft I mean under the water I was in the
dirt that doesn't matter
I was I was in the air I was I was under
the raft going the speed of the river
and I opened my eyes and the water was
so clear and I go you know what I guess
this is how I died
this is embarrassing this is like
embarrassing you're better than this
you're worth a better dad so I pop out
and I like sort of kick out and Aaron
sees me and he grabs me and pulls me
back into the boat that's so scary he
just yanked me so hard somewhere else
but it was no is that kind of trip yeah
yeah
and I was like how did you even get in
there button fly so anyway you want to
do the back it was a union suit like
gonzo head on Muppet Babies how did you
even wrap around to get my CAC so he but
anyway and I and I'm forever grateful
friend I actually hung out them last
night and he's the coolest guy so I have
a special feeling for Costa Rica because
not only we have a great time but I've
met one of my great friends you did he
was and I love him he's a great he's a
great comic it's on my bucket list and I
have no one to travel with and I haven't
taken a trip in forever let's do it
cheap I know and I all I want to do is
zip line surf raft play with monkeys
it's all there to Nicole I don't care
about that for the record if you're hot
and you do about it with the amount of
stuff that people are put on IMDB by the
way right now
yeah I saw guys paid today and I was
like this what literally anything you
make a YouTube you're like this is a
series it's 100 percent I know how about
this we got to get out of here in a
minute but I want to hear have you had
any really bad date fails lately
anything terrible any hookups on your
trip that went awry I told this story so
I'm going to a guy's wedding and
somebody asked me how did I meet this
guy and because he lives in Belfast I'm
going in a few weeks and it's a good
weird like because he doesn't live here
and I'm close enough where he's not
inviting a lot of people to the wedding
but he was I'd be honored if you came
and so I was like yeah I'll that if I'm
not working I'd love to go and I
somebody was like how did you meet him
and I realized I met him on the one of
the weirdest dates I've ever been on in
my life and so I was at I got asked to
or I was like hey I have somebody that I
think you should meet and nobody ever
sets me up like I'm just not somebody
who people are like I think you're gonna
love this person so I it was for me I
was just like why not I'll try it out
like it never happens to me and if this
person who I used to be pretty close
with was like you will like this person
this will be great so we met up nothing
there was no sparks on my side of it it
was just kind of like but I felt like
you know like she's come all the way
there and I was like you know give it a
chance don't be so judgmental right away
like be whatever so I choose where do
you want to go and I go I wherever you
want to go like let's just go hang out
or whatever she was do you want to go to
Soho House and I was like okay sure
whatever so we go there we're sort of
having like a like indie comedy movie
conversation where there is nothing
going there's no dialogue for 10 pages
you know it's just like awkward shots
and there's maybe like some hans zimmer
music in the background and and so i'm
kind of sitting there and this guy comes
up to me and he's pissed drunk and he's
like he's like I really like to show I'm
a fan I never do this to anybody can I
buy you a drink
and I was like and he noticed that I was
on a date and he goes I don't mean to
interrupt you but I just want to say
like I travel a lot and you're the only
show that I watch on my iPad and it's
like when I'm on these long flights a
little just watch like whole seasons of
the show
so as far as I thank you for like
keeping me awake and stuff I think it's
really nice saying I'm like sure and
then he goes then I'll buy one for your
date as well and then he like sort of
joined the date and he was so drunk and
then he and I was like I really like
this guy like he was so nice so fun so
so then I felt and then and then when he
went to get the drinks I'm like I'm
really sorry like obviously I didn't
plan that I you know and then she's like
no that guy seemed like awesome so that
she's like no lie no right do you think
he's into me and so then we Hank we he
and I wind up hanging out and that he
brings over all of his group of friends
and so like he starts sitting and
talking with me and then she's like near
me but she starts talking to his friends
yeah and so it turned into like the
greatest night cuz then like um three
months later he invited me to his place
in Belfast for Christmas and I went up
my buddy and I stayed with him and his
brother in Belfast and we like hung out
on Christmas no way it was crazy
and so but it was like the weirdest
thing cuz the night was like oh man this
is not going well or not that it's not
going well but you think like there is
literally she's a terribly sweet human
being we I when I run into her now I'm
like good to see you again like how was
everything
she's very cool she's a super cool girl
but nothing was going on and it turned
out to be like and this guy is now I I
could say like one of the get very very
close friend that's how I am going was
wedding in a month or like in threes
yeah yeah it's a date fail that turned
into a friendship it was a date fail but
it was a friendship success well then
you don't hang out at silver house for a
wedding any date on dates
yeah I mean pretty much I mean there's a
guy I slept with like last year who I
still sext with that's pretty much it he
has an epic wiener yeah where's yeah New
York let me just say that you the way
you was like we lost a lot of good men
well I I didn't storm this [ __ ] do you
know we did the whole podcast and I
realized halfway through that I never
said who was on but it'll be in the
title Kevin Hart Kevin Hart and Paula
Poundstone
yeah York but you're Kevin Hart right
I'm wearing a necktie and a huge suit
I'm bouncing guys this has been Dave
bales I had Jonathan kite and Nicole
Aimee Schreiber who will be in all my
posts about this and the title I feel
like your listeners are property smart
above-average intelligence and I've done
this before and you have to know where
are you guys gonna be out this weekend
or what do you got coming up this
weekend I'm at I have a show in Atwater
and then Sunday night I think i'ma show
at the improv follow you they can
probably follow me on social media at
Nicole Aimee and I co le a IME yeah what
about you when this show airs I will
have been at Comedy Store last different
previous night except economy starts
tonight and the Laugh Factory tonight
and this weekend is my birthday so I'm
not doing anything all of my party well
there is now no I'm having no I know so
what's happening is a bunch of people my
buddy Freddy who do you know Freddy
Freddy right Freddy a bunch people are
flying out tonight in tomorrow and so
we're just it's a four-day weekend it's
Labor Day so it's like word literally
just gonna be partying partying and I
think and I have no air conditioning
it's
we are going we are we're gonna k-town
karaoke perfect so drink your happy
birthdays to add Jonathan kite private
room okay at Jonathan kite at Jonathan
kite
hey ite you [ __ ] Charlottesville
people yeah don't you go there is there
a my podcast don't you go you go there
jujitsu and Nicole and I are starting
another podcast all about pooping which
I can't wait for you guys have you ever
[ __ ] your pants I don't tell the story
now you don't even need to [ __ ] your
pants or any fabulous poop or later so I
have one quick thing that I just a sneak
peek at it I'm like auditioning for you
guys to be on the show okay so I have
OCD and I don't like to poop in public
bathrooms or I can't do it and like I
remember one day I was with a buddy and
my dad and we were in an somewhere and
they're like if you have to go just go
and I go and I literally became like a
Larry David thing where I was like I
don't want to get a butt ass disease I
could have asked things and then they're
like looking at me like are you crazy
and I go no you're crazy for not
believing in ass disease as disease I
just there's so much [ __ ] but just like
I'm like so so um what happened was but
the one place that I will [ __ ] that
nobody will [ __ ] is an airplane yeah for
sure but but knew but people who are
like she will [ __ ] everywhere they'll
[ __ ] in church they'll [ __ ] and they'll
shouldn'ta pool they're like those shits
in the pool babies who don't know any
better how dare you ban them
I've never [ __ ] in a pool and I've said
no a lot of time yeah yeah when old
people
I'll be [ __ ] everywhere just so your
kqs you just like over you and a monkey
you're just gonna swallow all the time
I'll do it in airplanes all the time
because they don't you're down you're
trapped by the way and I'm not gonna sit
in a seat and get you just like be that
uncomfortable I'm like it's fine and
first I would rather you go [ __ ] then
sit next to me in fart that pisses me
off
oh I will light it
No I can't help it it's pressure my body
is experiencing pressure do you know
that whenever I fly my boobs hurt
because I have implants and the implants
like I think on planes the implants kind
of blow up a little bit so if you say
Kate and a plane her tits are not that
big guys that is that that's what
today's leading up to I did not even
think it's true I get off the plane and
I'm like why they she's like I'm a
double D she's like I'm an F come one is
blowing up bigger and it looks like the
Klumps and let's take the Nutty
Professor when his lip just goes and
you're like it's true and if the plane
crashes I don't need someone think is he
motorboating her I'm like I'm doing it
for us I think that's enough this has
been Dave fails you guys have been
amazing I love you love you guys check
out the patreon patreon comm backslash
Kate cute funny and please donate money
to Nicole
[Applause]
[Music]